alright so we just saw a liter battle
angel sorry Philippe review I was out of
town so just catching up on a few flicks
I know I'm awful uh 5ai Julie this is a
long day because you just got back so we
did let's see we would watch so we were
talking like spoilers
[Laughter]
no I'm just saying like my voice is sore
and I'm trying to wonder where I'm like
oh yeah we've been talking all day yeah
now that we did how to train your dragon
earlier because we saw that weeks ago
yeah
so we were talking all throughout next
room for the real thought so now we've
got like this yeah we saw a movie which
of course we talked to author actually
we did because they were hardly anybody
in the house but but we should movie so
I was shouting a yeah but but we
should build up we actually caused a lot
of people going it's like I don't know
what the anime is like or the manga or
anything we had to do up history some
other favorites uh uh well battle angel
is actually the first anime I've ever
seen I'm sure I've seen like Speed Racer
and with Transformers County on VHS and
yeah 96
maybe melee 95 96 yeah and an an RT
tried to recommend to me similarly for
so it was very close to yeah she said I
know what yeah do you know what your
Panda mation is back what Jim and I'm
like I don't know I think so like the
big eyes and I kind of thing and she
said and she said well that's apropos
for the movie yes exactly uh and she
said you all see this uh
thing called battle angel and just as
soon as I saw that image of like just
the girl the crazy hair but like the
really you know beaten up robotic body
and this cool coat the long time I mean
it was just is everything I loved in an
image I felt was badass pretty much you
know that's why you use no it's like I
try to get that imagery like a devil
boner and stuff like that the crazy hair
the crazy outfit stuff under the eye so
I just fell in love with it and I liked
it there's only two of them uh the obas
but but we both like them and there's a
huge influence outside
yeah and it's the first weird okay so if
you grew up in
you saw a lot of anime and didn't
realize it cuz Nickelodeon was
challenging yeah it's not that we hadn't
seen anime but this was the first really
adult anime be wet but before Akira
I'm not gonna cure you we saw Garrett
after bad battle angel OVA so so so this
was like a big thing and then only last
week was on vacation I read the first
volume of the manga because I saw at the
bookstore I'm like I should probably
read this now I read the whole manga but
that was 15 years yeah and what I liked
where my memory is like decent enough
but I'm a little sketchy and some things
but what I like is they were different
wasn't a direct word-for-word seem by
see like they were hilarious basic idea
but but they were there and they started
tapped into different themes and I you
know but with the same general outline
so I really like that okay but it had to
because it was like if I remember the
OVA was only like an hour long but all
of that into one he was sort of themes
they focus on are a little different
which I like I'm really happy for a
Sora's prose and you shouldn't bring
something new a table including this
movie yeah so so we have this movie
that's not like a direct direct
adaptation which again I'm very thankful
for but but it does still keep the same
idea kind of the same it's a michmash
they move things around but they also
add a few things its bizarrely a
combination of the OVA and the manga
yeah which if you're wondering how they
got away with that it's because James
Cameron bought the rights to both I
think really and which is why because I
love battle Angelita and I'm like why
haven't we gotten an anime all these
other things get remade into animes and
spin-off series and the lead I never got
it when it wasn't hugely successful in
Japan but two with the popularity here
the cult following here you would have
thought that somebody would capitalize
it's because Cameron bought the rights
in 98 they can't make yeah which after
if the maker of Titanic came to me and
said I want to bite though right that'd
be yeah buy whatever you want maybe I
don't imagine that quisha bear casino is
like sitting there going like okay at
the time I think he was was the monk is
still going an idea
he may have been finished but he's got
to look at this like the guy who made
the most money on a film ever just one
God knows how many Academy Awards wants
to make this in it all right but I don't
think anybody including us realized that
that meant we were gonna have to sit on
this for 21 wellhe's what did you this
movie for years I think even longer than
avatar
until finally he just said I'm never
gonna get this damn thing made I'll just
give it to someone else I'll produce it
and in my opinion how's a good choice
because I really dug it
I saw the trailers and I cried and they
were not tears of joy they were oh my
god I was excited another beloved anime
another anime that I love is gonna get
destroyed it's gonna be like ghost in
the shell' that's gonna like why God why
and then when I got into this about ten
minutes in them like this is pretty
solid and then it was after the first
action sequence right just turned to you
and I'm like alright we're good yeah I
need to see how they did a fight yeah
how the fight went down and when I saw
the fight and it was awesome I'm like I
alright I was wrong I get a minute
I was wrong now I will say this I love
this movie I'll go into all the reasons
why is a lot of reasons why for the
first half of this movie I was saying
what the is wrong with people I
know this is awesome percent why yeah
we're just old not bad I mean it's over
half and stuff by me it's one of those
things where it's like yeah like a
really high up there and about halfway
even though I still was loving it I was
saying away you know what I'm seeing why
some people sort of to draw chinks in
the armor started sharing yeah and we'll
get into those too but uh let's just go
into what what I love about this movie
first of all the cast feels like it's
nothing but IDO character and I will say
this even even looking at the trailer
the second it's like Christoph Waltz
like perfect you know I'm like you could
not have created a human being to look
more like even just put the glasses on
give him the Hat
give him the trench coat
so the the casting in this movie there
are only two people I think it didn't
work and they're not awful they they
just didn't work at how they price
should have but the casting I'm just
like first rate everyone even the side
care just because I miss this in movies
they feel like 80s character ages
because they use it to fill moving time
makes this feel like the lost 80s film
that never what's amazing uh the the
violence I I don't know what it's I
didn't want to smile and I was gonna say
I think it's a g13 but it wishes an are
a little more they pulled an alien
versus Predator where it's like yeah
it's pg-13 but they they have some blue
poles like all of their machine so you
can do whatever they want they just
changed the color blood they're still
getting mangled pudding machines their
heads are getting crushed i we saw their
organs flying everywhere I was a little
bit too rules where they're just like we
can't get like an X rating or whatever
well we'll just make the blood green and
black color yeah that's still gory as
hell yeah but but it's still it's still
there but it still Rodriguez film uh the
fact that's Robert Rodriguez I love the
out Robert Rodriguez I know people
think of probably don't cuz I make fun
of them but the some of the kids feel
system by legitimately spine notes is
its own different but even though it's
okay
for what they are I want a few they
loved the second Sin City uh and it's
nice to see just like I don't see a
return to form because like I said Niall
Sin City but yeah there is just a night
its aggressive it's an aggressive movie
it's a great story and they here's the
other thing like a lot of CGI battles to
me kind of feel they've a lot of times a
lack like an oomph where it's just like
yeah these are just CGI characters I
don't feel the impacts are real man not
in this movie like the fights I'm just
like well I feel like these things are
really beating the cramping the CGI I
mean in in my opinion I think they're
pretty much almost every character is as
good as Gollum from Lord of the Rings in
my opinion now Gollum do not know God a
little gunk didn't always like 100%
realistic you know they're playing you
know PCG a lot of time you're like damn
it really looks like he's there and I
watching the trailer and I still a lot
of times watching this movie I'm just so
blown away that the woman who plays
Aleta uh none of her is there it is like
on where they look at the facial
expressions they say okay well we'll
transfer that but like all of the scg
the clothes the hair the fate everything
is CG and now that I've seen it on the
big screen I will say this you can tell
okay I'm across so it's definitely now
you you put him up to me like a bitch to
do something huh huh I'm like what it's
just like her entire body's like no
screen I can't really no well I say
let's get this right I said how much of
her do you think is CGI equal the eyes
obviously I'm like yeah that the fade
the face is what I was going maybe a
little bit the face I said 100% the
clothes the shoes and everything is he
doing oh yeah well okay but no on the
small screen it's a little well the
textures were hit miss if it's a
metallic or plastic like her first body
with the plastic texture it's pretty
realistic her sweater and stuff not not
so much I just really thought of her
pants like it just depends but that's
the thing we're seeing it in IMAX on the
small screen sure like I probably wasn't
thinking about who I was watching the
trailer and I'm like yeah but like now
that I've seen it on the big screen I'm
like yeah no it's not it's not bad CGI
no I'm considering considering what
they're putting her through it like
because original like why why do you
need to CGI her entire character having
seen the movie now I'm like okay I get
it
I get why you needed to do that there's
other design choices I have issues with
that we'll get into but I'm just like I
get why they needed to CGI but if you're
asking like yeah it does look like CGI
it's not something where the movie if I
also watch this movie going in not
knowing that I would assume they only
did the eyes and then after a while yes
you pick up easy than the skin on the
Sloane's are so smokey you can sell now
looking but which was I would not have
guessed the right here your excuse which
i think is valid enough
is well she's supposed to be artificial
yeah and I'm like that that works as an
excuse my only problem is CGI has this
quality of feeling like it's not really
there so even if it's she supposed to be
artificial there was still times I'm
like yeah she just feels like she was
digitally inserted in sometimes not all
the times but sad that's my issue with
these into the fight scenes or of course
she's all CG there I doubt there's even
data motion capture or anything and so
like they were hitting miss where I'm
just like oh no really looks like she's
there another time like that when they
did the
I I am getting a little sick of V haha
we're gonna fight in that pseudo-snot
speed up again I feel like there's not
that they were they were way more house
my big they were made they were way more
judicious with it and I'm like you know
it okay I'll take this every once in a
while yeah there were a couple there
were a couple of them that were really
cool it I mean anime has speed lines and
stuff but I don't see that particular
technique employed a thousand times like
it is over here no no okay here I mean
when they do slow-mo it's like
somebody's flying and then you'll hear
the inner thought of the person flying
and the speed lines are going it's like
well technically that's not slow-mo
because the speed lines are going like
that but if they're really going that
fast to be over in a second but somehow
they're flying for a minute yeah that's
something that a stylized animation can
kind of get away with no but that's what
I'm saying
this is their version of that that's
this is their version of you I love
their conversion SP lines I should say
oh you say so it looked like a lot of
superhero movies to be or Marvel movies
where they pull that kind of thing you
know but I agree I disagree but if we're
both kinda getting sick of it but
there's not that much of it here now
they did just enough where I'm like okay
don't you know more but we're good we're
good the the acting in this I think like
I said and about 90% of it I love you
Jen Huck and I just want to throw that
yeah I don't know I missed Jennifer
Connelly
but I'm trying to think if I ever saw is
like a villain in something and I was
just like man she's like she's just got
Jen's like watch she was like one of my
first crushes like though know me too
I'm not gonna not land yeah Rocketeer
I'm a labyrinth we were to like a little
too young but she was too annoying about
you but Rocketeer though just
yeah it's like you just hit that age
where it's just like Oh am I like into
girls now and she comes out singing that
sultry song in the laughs I'm just like
yes yes I well technically she said the
song in derg City she did where he
similar dress she wore the dress that's
right yeah
close it does Timothy Dalton suppose
Neville Sinclair but but so ah that's
right then you know they're very word
we're getting off topic but I just was a
they're very similar roles her role in
Dark City and that what's an outfit step
yeah yeah but but that's the thing she
always kind of played these roles where
they she played them file I saw house of
Santa Fogg she was very very good in
that but she mostly just I should say um
how the drug requiem for a dream she
wasn't very good in that oh yeah but but
something here where she's like the you
know it just gives you the death glare
from far away like the first time she
since you do she just walks into you
just has this death glare just like she
like she's straight I'm not like she was
giving off that kind of Michael Keaton
sort of like I don't have to say much
you'll just go complex personality out
of my expression that's so many of the
people in this movie are like yeah and I
was very miss that uh in that some
Rodriguez always has down man does he
cast his movies just so well I mean you
think of just the the actors in Sin City
instead and he must direct them well to
cuz I in Sin City half of them never
even met and you just swear I thought
I've talked about a bit of a stroke of
genius to retain her character because
her characters not in the manga hmm
that's a no via the Sheeran is in the
OVA and then crushing Grushenka what is
his name the big bag and if he's in the
OVA
but they kept those over and I like the
way it kind of fused the two so this
feels like okay this is in the OVA or
the manga now we're fusing those two so
this is now a third iteration that feels
different which I thought was super cool
and it gave her like a chance to kind of
craft an interesting character out of it
yeah there's um every and anytime in the
movie it's kinda like Aquaman anytime it
starts to feel long like okay yeah it's
time to feel the length a little bit as
something cool would happen
just be like okay and I'm back I'm back
in this movie there's two things in my
opinion that do not work and they're not
awful but they are the two things I'm
like okay I can see why some people like
the chinks in the armor can't really
start the show there one is the
boyfriend in this I think you go yeah is
miscast I don't we don't we don't hate
this actor it don't know he's trying
it's just like it's it's not the one
from either the OVA or the mom no it's
pretty much this character and you can
tell even by the end this is supposed to
be someone he's big eyed and hopeful and
he wants to get to this place and all
sorts of terrible things happen along
the way and they're supposed to be like
he's charming but they're supposed to be
kind of a street rat pathetic like he
lives on the streets thing and the
stairs way too much this guy's way too
much of like a you know surfer body you
know hey yeah I won't go to the city of
that you know guy looks like he dropped
out of every young adult movie ever made
yeah like yeah like you yeah any of
these why a novels like it just looks
like he was just pieced together from
man and his act exactly fine like I feel
it is I feel bad because we're gonna
dump on him a bit but it's not as just
miscast yeah it Hugo is supposed to be
such a level of would you say pathetic
yeah he can be a little tough to you but
there is this he-he's the nobody the
person that people just kick out the way
and he's like I'm gonna be something
here's my problem
his is supposed to be like a big tragedy
where is and this one they played off
more like he's Canada from Akira a
little more to you guys a little to put
together and that it just wasn't gelling
and then at the end like my only the
problem where I started to lose it with
the movie again I we won't we'll try not
to give anything away here yeah give a
general the the ending to the
VA has a real emotional weight to it
like it's super powerful it's a great
visual the characters the the characters
involved just seem crazed like it's
really just crazy and sad and tragic to
watch and then this one which should be
a tragedy comes off as just like mom am
yeah yeah like it yeah it's just he's
got a I'm just doing this man what you
know where it's like yeah there is kind
of like an insanity there's an insanity
to the rest of the movie you know what
characters that feel like you do not
imagine your to imagine your here's the
best way I can put it imagine you're
telling the exact same story but in the
OVA you get Michelle Pfeiffer as Selena
Kyle but in the movie you get Anne
Hathaway as Selena Kyle it's like one
was really complex deep and crazed and
this and that and then you've got and
half yeah she was fine and the Dark
Knight Rises but it's like it but if
you're telling that if they're supposed
to be the exact same character they're
not but let's imagine you're remaking
that movie no that doesn't work like
they're completely different and the the
second problem that is a major problem
but again I didn't mind cuz it's done
well enough but it's not that there's
necessary too much going on it's that
the motivations behind everybody they're
there but they're not super well-defined
you read the manga it's like we have the
advantage I feel like had I not done
either I might have been a little more
lost it's like no it's like I filed it
but okie says simple question what's the
you know a lot of things happen in Lord
of the Rings but what's it about this
ring that this bad guy had they have to
get rid of it you know inception it's a
super complicated story but what's it
about that to go on a dream to get this
information to get their lives back got
it this one what's it about it's like
well this yeah girl has a past as
robotic body and then she meets this boy
but then there's like this motor ball
thing and then there's the city up there
she kinda watch he gets to but then
first you it's like it's not where
simple this is motivation I have to give
so much credit to that OVA I know some
people don't like it's like they
truncated the manga it's
but they cherry picked in such a way
that they gave you a pretty sissing
story and it's like no it's about this
girl who was put back together and it's
about this kid and they're both trying
to get up there it's this journey this
climb up and the the tragedy of it and
the like you're right about this because
when they started to get back to that
whole plot idea it was like the last 30
minutes and like they're reintroducing
it again like we got to go up to Salem
all right and I'm just like oh yeah that
still maybe yeah a movie where is it I
said feather blade rollerball for a bit
yeah it felt way more like a focus in
the OVA because they had to truncated
and condense it down into that and the
the rollerball to me I I enjoyed I
enjoyed her playing the street get overs
and of rollerball or we're on in the
movie than I did the actual rollerball
sequences I thought it was pretty cool
but again there was a little bit more
motivation yeah she's trying to get the
attention of the boy and she's trying to
learn her body and everything where's
the other one it's like okay I guess
we're doing this to get money you know
on here's here's the problem it's just
the effects overall are really good
there was something about the rollerball
it was reminding me a little vaguely of
like the Wachowski Speed Racer movie
where I'm like man now I just feel like
I'm watching 99.9% fakery oh yeah it was
really like it doesn't feel like
everybody's cool yeah I mean they say
this so the interesting thing about this
is she feels more softer rounder around
the edges personality-wise more girlish
in this one versus the OVA or the manga
draw versus know where she's constructed
in this movie base I have a bit of a
criticism with that but but but I'll get
to it I do really like the way because
she's done but um but I'll say this
it did me I'm not saying that as a I'm
not saying that as a criticism
I'm not saying oh because they made her
cuter in this than in the manga or the
OVA that therefore it's bad in some ways
it makes a little more interesting
because they do evolve her character and
by the time she
was up at rollerball that's her in the
OVA and the manga like all of a sudden
I'm just like it was like flash I'm like
oh there she is like almost like they've
been developing her to a point that now
it's just like now she's truly badass
like she's gonna take these bastards out
then I thought it made the roller like
the roller balls seem probably wouldn't
have been as interesting to me if it
didn't have that vibe of like yeah and
now we're gonna see her really kick ass
and now yeah she knows we were like she
did there she knows the odds are against
her even more than before when I seen
that happens and she doesn't run away
she's like you know okay and just like
who which which ones want to kill me oh
yeah and they set it up again very much
I get a manga that that's kind of if not
just the brain but kind of body that she
has now that motivation that that's the
one thing I'm shocked they didn't do
more than this because that feels like
the most cinematic to me is in the manga
they have it where it's like yeah she's
kind of everyday you know run the mill
girl you know she likes boys she likes
to flirt of it and stuff but the body
that she's given the poker body sort of
changes her mind a little bit I love
that battle between mind and body
literally mind and body and I thought
that would have been interesting when
she got the berserker and this like it
kind of changed her around too but it
did it doesn't quite she's already kind
of on her way there and it's still good
progression but I thought that is such
an interesting element and even the big
bad guy the one that she's hunting for a
while they tap on that in the manga to
think he talks about you know way became
when he got his body or you know going
from mind to mind body to body and how
it changes you and it's like that would
have been so fascinating but I also get
there's a lot going on - yeah and I'll
say this the world building in this yeah
is a sight to behold like this is
definitely a film you should see on the
big screen in IMAX 3d looks great it
just destroyed cities have we seen we're
tired of it it's been done to death it
looks beautiful
all credit to casinos to casinos mom
go for that because if you read their
manga it's gorgeous and like some of the
operatic city yeah yeah is amazing and
you could tell they just took one look
at that and and and and the OVA which
had a more limited budget
definitely compared to this but like
they took they looked at both in just
like alright let's do this let's take as
many hard drives as it takes you know
and and punch this world out and I I
thought it was amazing I thought for the
scenes that look you know like oh that's
obviously CG oh that looks a little fake
whatever like the stuff that was not
distracting to me and looks legit' him
Liga I mean that one bounty hunter that
that was kind of hunting her I mean I'm
just look at him I'm like I know he's CG
but he just looked so good I mean like
so much of that body was just looking so
good but and it's a typical Terminator
body and it seemed so good and I know we
like it as a guilty pleasure because we
thought it was so bad it's good like it
was hilariously awful of it like train
wreck this is the movie valerian wanted
to be like I feel looking at this in all
the world building that's an uncool yeah
but it's gorgeous there's CGI everywhere
but where is valerian we were kind of
laughing at it it was just so I laughed
at this movie a lot but I was laughing
because I was having a great time like
yeah yeah like that ha ha I can't
believe they went with that yeah and I
feel like the only thing missing like I
said I think really what just made this
a pure awesome 80 flick you know like
80s so I'm gonna be a little more adult
Gore yes I really think like and like I
said they get away with a lot don't get
me wrong but literally I think like I
don't know page for some of the manga
like the the big you know the big strong
robot this just takes someone rips open
their heads with their eyes flying out
and stuff and eats his brains yeah I
mean there is so much brain in the other
and that's what and this is James
Cameron he's done some very gory movies
so I really thought man that's gonna be
cool we're gonna get that here and um do
you think they shot it originally like
that kind of stuck because with the blue
blood coming out of them and even so
thousand bucks it's like when they kill
the you know it's always blue blood
because what they when they slice up
when Ito gets his arm sliced and and you
go gets cut up like you see red blood
the blue blood I think was always to
just delineate between humans and
cyborgs and they said like ash in Alien
has white blood but but like but like
there's a scene where say again it's
it's not even a major character but
there's a scene where character gets his
head cut off and you see like these
little wires and stuff but the character
is supposed to be dead I'm like but wait
would it be more clear if when they kill
them you know people aren't coming out
and I'm thinking myself I wonder if it
was blood I wonder if they'll like they
just changed it up I don't know but I
don't know but that is the one thing
where I'm like man this would have been
like Robocop man that's what bother me
cuz I'm like this is one step removed
from a fair home in film yeah like it's
just like yeah extra steps like this is
an 80s movie and then part of it's
because the the manga started in 1990
and the OVA was like 90 force of it I
already felt old to begin with but it's
just like yeah this has that cyberpunk
80s vibe to it just with this 90s kid
for some reason as the loving with every
character that pops up in this aren't
you immediately like who's that don't
you want to know I mean just uh just see
them and you're like I won't know more
about that person I would accept what
moment for okay I forget one other
casting choice I didn't think again not
awful but I'm like oh I knows is I don't
worry you don't way for Ito Ito Eidos
assistant in this remember how he looked
in the replace them with this actress
who does somebody but is totally
forgettable and but the one in the comic
and the and the end is just this
what a great decisis very guys I just
wanna again one of those nights where
you say I want know more about this guy
this one is just like some lazy I got so
wrapped up in the movie I I wasn't even
thinking about that that much but ya
know you're 100% correct
but my basket validated like everyone
else I think we leaned over at some
point I'm just like man like everyone in
this is interesting I think my only my
only gripe below the the ending which I
have to punch in the the ova like track
down the OVA and watch if you can cuz
the final image of that I'll just say
with the balloon well I'm just telling
ya out there and it's it's very poetic
one of its one of the best endings to an
anime I've seen it was a very poetic
image and this one just sequel Bates at
the end so all of that emotional oomph
that you had in the OVA it's literally
just like what we're gonna do that same
scene really quickly it's gonna be
coming uh-oh
bye and then it's just literally like
sequel baiting like yeah I'm coming for
you yes moving that doesn't even feel
like it has a climax like like again for
a fur the ova I mean the it the OPA is
really weird because like it's two and a
half hours special but like a lot of
people died in these two half hours you
know more than this two-hour movie um
that's like the manga was even done yet
so this is like know this might be our
only chef but that's what I'm saying is
that they still had climaxes at the end
and they felt like they were kind of
building up to this where this one it's
like bunch of cool you're following
it and then just oh that's kind of cool
and then this game that's kind of cool
and then that's good and then and then
it's just kind of over like I needed a I
can legitimately say like it and I
remember turning to you and I'm like all
right up until the last five minutes I
was pretty much in love with this movie
and like this ending is the only thing I
hate and I'm like this ending sucks like
compared to what it could have been and
what you had in the OVA and yeah and a
lot like that doesn't really end they
like that volume and I think volume one
ends where we think like that continues
into volume two but it yeah so so I
didn't like that and then I I don't like
the eyes I can't I I just I I think is
Claire I think if she's only getting
this play I know Brandon Tamara said
look I totally forgot about the eyes and
I know I've heard other people III don't
I didn't there's AI guess whenever there
is a close-up I was just like God
just like jeanine got the bug eyes again
and later sorry about the bug i thinkI
my office i I can't have like I don't
get that I mean yeah there are a couple
times where just everything looks so
real it's like oh yeah those giant eye
the weird thing is from a distance now
the long shots of her where she's like
you can see her whole figure and she's
gotta be like 30 feet away from the
camera
I mean digitally inserted but you know
she looked fine like because the eyes
kind of everything kind of shrinks down
and I'm like okay if I don't focus on
the eyes at that distance
she looks like a normal like kind of
human being like but got in those
close-ups it was driving me up a wall
yeah I don't I don't get I don't get the
excuse like I've heard this excuse like
well in the anime they've got big eyes
it doesn't matter but they all have big
eyes
oh yes that's the point I think there's
like well she's got a have big eyes cuz
she was drawing that way in the manga
she looks no different in the manga than
anybody else from what I remember they
all have big eyes so in this one she's
the isn't far as I remember in this
movie she's the only character with
bigger oh one other one there was one of
the other models I guess but I'm just
like but that just kept because then I
kept sitting there in the middle of the
flashlights going like so why did they
make these models have big eyes who's
not the artist but but even then you can
immediately tell them apart to it which
I like but but to me I think so many
people do want to see I mean I think
it's fair to say so many people wanna
see an anime come to life they want to
see a live-action representation okay
grease on either no no I get that
yeah it's like what's wrong with you I
get it but I think that was such a
clever way because she is a robot now is
she a robot but she's one that's like
really really old and super advanced and
like really distinct and people would
look at her and be like they're cyborgs
everywhere but like I see her and it's
like who's that and so I really think
that is if there would be no other way
to imply that she's different no we had
to give her big eyes and that's what but
it's somewhat it you know it's strange
that when you think about like you were
created as the universe's ultimate
battle machine and we gave you giant
cute Google guys like it
so we'd like why would you do that that
doesn't even make any sense from a
design choice yes
maybe what I've seen more I don't know
but it's like yes anime has big eyes
that is a stylistic choice it came from
a fact that early on I think it was an
homage to basically Tezuka and other
people who were sort of copying Disney
and then the Japanese also the kind of
you eyes is like a window to the soul so
that the larger more innocent the eyes
and indicates you're an innocent
character and then villains will often
have like kind of shady eyes or they'll
be squinty or so so the idea is you
can't see into them it means they're
like complex or evil where so it's a
stylistic choice and they all have that
it's not just like Oh Alito was the only
one drawn with big eyes so why make her
the only one with big eyes in the back
but I feel like characters like again
come going back to Gollum you know he
has these big eyes you know and Lord the
Rings of course he's been alive for
years and years oh he's gonna look like
that you know so that's you a mutant the
ring gives you big up but she's a robot
you know and out everybody says you know
something about her Stan says something
is different about her because there's a
million cyborgs in this and that's
something that no the others have and
that stands out and she looks much more
like the anime characters so makes her
stay in order the manga she can kill you
with a flick of the wrist
I just doesn't stand a girl's guy yeah I
I don't know if it did it in no way
rekted the movie it didn't wreck the
movie I'm not saying I can still go see
it absolutely but he really wasn't on
those things I'm like no I never did get
over that I'm like if I were if you
threw a hundred million dollars at me
and they're just like we make parts of
this movie I'm like step one remove
those eyes you want to keep her entirely
CGI all right maybe we can do that
because I see why they did that now I
get it too it makes her look freakish
too which I like that she is kind of an
outcast she is kind of the one that's
like what are youyou we're freaky weird
thing you've it and that just said they
didn't do that my favorite was it was a
Jennifer Connelly like one of the
characters said it's like you're so
beautiful and I'm just like is she
really
like I do remember that I was just like
was that what you were gone for like
maybe she looks great but it's not like
wow what a beautiful danger you know you
little angel but it tastes like I will
give it I'll give it this had they gone
the wrapped like if this is supposed to
be like Dumbo where they make fun of his
big ears had they gone the route where
they're just like what's up with your
eyes like and they like your eyes are
weird and like basically like make
yourself conscious they see so much
weird anyway it has to be some
that's weird but like is distinct as
well I mean it I don't know I I thought
that was a very clever both very small
and very big thing to help her stand
makes her look back upon was still
obsessed with his face his face seemed
pretty put together it seems like most
people when it comes to their face and
stuff she was the only one with those
eyes which means some of it will turn
like that that's what I mean yeah that's
why people be like well who who is that
what is that you know kind of thing so I
dad's like I don't get it they're big
they're freaky they can be distracting
I'm not I thought that added to what she
was and and everything else but I but I
get the weird thing is in doing so and I
said like I'm not against making her
character a little more naive innocent
like girlish in this one versus the OVA
among them right I felt like she was a
little more put together earlier on but
in giving her the big eyes she actually
looks less like the manga to me like it
just it doesn't look right I'm like God
she looks less like what we got in the
ouvea because in the OVA her eyes aren't
insanely huge as huge compared to some
other anime I've seen hmm so it just it
just doesn't come off right anyway I
slice it it's funny you were talking
about you know sir comparing or
different characters to to the OVA and
the manga is something I liked in the
manga again this goes back to the mind
versus body is that I really like when
you know most of the manga she said I'm
gonna find this person I'm gonna get
here I mean she's just so self driven
she's got the killer you know
instinct and then you know would say
something like you know wow you know
you're really maturing it you go Oh am I
like she'll suddenly go really
girlish like a girl her age now what or
when she sees that pie notice tree but
when she sees uh you go over the first
nine and she has a crush on and she
blushes and stuff and this monster that
she already defeated comes back up and
he's like stand back and she just goes
yeah I'm scared like she's doing and
then she kicks his ass like behind
without him noticing that's something
like a girl who has a crush would do
exam you know and I like that verse I
said I'm hoping a little bit earlier on
in this one she was just like she has
moments of badassery but it's definitely
like they're trying to portray her as
like no she's just a teenager and then
she involves which I'm not saying as a
bad especially for a two hour movie yeah
it's definitely different than the manga
that way and as somebody who was very I
had to get over because if somebody was
very used to the concept oh yeah she she
has those girlish moments but like then
she flips on a switch in his bad ass
again I was so used to the badass part
of Aleta that in this one initially I
was just like no but I got really really
the Cossack is kind of flipped yeah
obviously badasses and once in a while
she'd do like that kind of thing but I
got used to it and honestly like her
relationship with IDO like it was really
like legitimately sweet yeah in every
way that they're they're a little more
rougher I think in the OVA and the end
the manga and particularly in the manga
I don't think he was ever he's not the
Sharon is an in it like so there's no
wife character so it's like this guy
creating a doll it's like it's a little
bit has this Japanese sort of like old
guy commentary just like okay oh tak
you're like let's play with your doubles
but yeah he and God damns Christofle
it's good I just like it
even in crap I like him like I just feel
too ironic I just as I'm saying this did
you ever see him in bigger
yes and I'm not saying that he's but
just like rock that we bring up big guys
boat leave is both great and because
he's not great in that like I did I just
came out a 2 min anything that's the one
where I was just like what happened but
no he's he's really amazing and everyone
in here I mean like I said like 98% of
the actors just nail it's so good and
they're so interests and you handle they
they kept all of the key concepts like I
think something I really loved about
this manga and OVA and even this movie
is like it always felt very metropolis
inspired to me the haves the have-nots
the delineator garbage and then and then
particularly like it just keeps going
full circle because then we also had the
anime version of metropolis which also
reminds me of this and like I like all
three of those versions like metropolis
is one of my all versions of metropolis
are like my favorite movie I love the
anime version I love the of the old it's
one of those stories that really has
everything doesn't and like everything
you can kind of like so stylized that
kind of art deco vibe and it it's just
great and this manages to be like it's
the farthest from metropolis in both
style but it just has that vibe to it
where I'm like I recognized this as a
metropolis story even though this is
cyberpunk whereas those like the
original my travels I don't watch even
call I may be like steampunk ID like I
don't know what it is and then the the
anime I guess would be kind of a little
more cyberpunk
but it I don't know like those themes I
think are like Universal it's very like
monomyth thousand faces type stuff where
it just you feel like this story will
never accept full crap on the poor and
needy and love that cable that was my
favorite thing in the oba and climbing
the cable climbing the cable and the the
the evil guys up top just launching the
little angry the bus like Jesus Christ
man you know it doesn't make even like
yeah we'll wrap this up Sam but they
even like without giving away too much
in the OVA just like that again we're
not gonna wait til my butt but climbing
the cable what a big deal that wasn't
how much time they dedicated to that cuz
they were just happens it's you just
kind of die anything yeah it is like
like for those for those who have not
seen the OVA or read the manga or do
that just to know because when people
like why didn't read it I don't know
what's different that it's not different
in that they changed the plot point it's
different in that the way so little
emphasis on it and like that is one of
the central themes of the OVA and to see
it just so glossed over like okay that
is the death of Gwen Stacy like that's
the best we could think of the death of
Gwen Stacy and spider-man and think
about how they did it in amazing
spider-man 2 that's the difference you
don't look at it and go it's like oh
well it's completely different like no
she still falls off she still dies
spider-man can't save her in time the
green Goblin's above but when you look
at the execution of it you're just like
wow did they blow it yeah so there's no
spoilers on this movie but spoilers on
who doesn't know that now who even
people don't watch my biggest race but I
do like despite those smaller gripes I
hope this movie does well I know it's
it's not a complete bomb but it's not
making the money they wanted it to and
their eye or the mouth
I hope word of I don't know with how the
dream dragon coming out they're banking
on overseas which is the ultimate irony
because the OVA when it was released in
Japan wasn't a hit Japan wasn't a hit in
Japan it better hitter went overseas was
a huge hit here has this cult following
which is why came and grabbed it up sat
on it for 21 years so nobody else could
do anything now it's released now it's a
failure here and hopefully maybe Japan
can go save it I don't know or China I
can see why some people don't get all
the way into it but I think the stuff
that's really good in this is so freakin
cool so entertaining so creative such a
visual wonder and the characters are
likable and it's just I would write
awesome movie absolutely yeah was a huge
doubter yeah like this is one that I'm
gonna I'm gonna freakin eat my words of
the rest of the year like
because the bar has been set so low for
anime adaptation that's true I mean
adaptation might be absolutely I did
again I think in making the other one I
mean fake mostly been bad was it gonna
be the DBZ movie like what robbed a
little masterpiece called Death Note
yeah in the shell with Scarlett
Johansson no like this is hands-down the
best the anime adaptation I've ever seen
it feels like an anime and it it nailed
most things right yeah I don't know I
we've seen I believe read volume 1 of
the manga so I don't know the entire
story I mean it seems like it is but so
I don't know like all of it at the same
time I'm feeling like even people that
don't like they might feel like they're
missing a finger too but it's like I
feel like they would follow it and enjoy
it watch this not get all of it but go
man I'm really interested a lot more
maybe I'll pick up the manga maybe I'll
watch the Oviatt things or the rings
that aren't entirely made clear and then
the Apple want to go and read the book
but they're still a mess I'm hoping
that's what happens I think going with
that mindset that you may not know every
single thing that's going on here though
I thought they did a damn good job of it
I never I never I felt like even if I
didn't read the manga or see the OVA I
wouldn't be lost Christoph Waltz was
getting a little exposition he at some
point I was kinda like okay there's only
some chicken here well this does that
this person is it he does it so wasn't
his exposition worse than anything in
the Avengers and look at what a
moneymaker that is no and he is so good
at he's so good at just awful yeah he
sells that when he showed up in that bed
the hunter outfit for the first time I
was there's a couple Caesar I was like
but yeah I I think it's super cool I
there's problems there and some people
might get a little lost but I I think
it's totally worth it like I would go
see it like please throw money at this
yeah I went into the spider-verse we're
like yeah go
I know we didn't know at the time that
people are gonna respond to it or not
because like yeah we didn't know and
then like it turns out everybody loves
it but at the time I'm like I don't know
if people are gonna like this but please
throw your yeah hopefully yeah really
throw your money at this and I'll say
this if it's not exist success and they
don't want to make more God's sakes
James Cameron just do the anime then
just like make a 13-episode series
making the Netflix show man come on you
could get through the whole manga in a
Netflix series they had multiple
episodes of season so it like do that
because that is the only thing that's
bothered me about him sitting on the
rights is I'm like I've wanted an anime
of Alita like something that delves
deeper than the ova yeah for 20 odd
years now and we haven't gotten it
because he opens it yeah so like a man
you know I are people liking this I
don't know I know critics are very very
mixed um if I had to guess I would say
people are probably mixed but I don't
know maybe people are loving it maybe
they're not I don't know but the mixed
critical response it doesn't seem like
there's enough to really be like no I
can't recommend it like even most
cynical critics would be grudgingly
recommend and be like all rights got a
lot of problems and you know it's better
than some of the other things we get no
it could be because it's not Titanic
it's not avatar it's an action cyberpunk
movie and that could be why they're
thinking well I want the next grass
hilarious cuz I thought this movie was
way better than Avatar love what I loved
about avatar was the visuals there was
nothing about that story I don't
that's why it pisses me off I'm like may
not be the same visual it may not be as
visually impressive as avatar but this
one has impressive visuals and the story
is actually good yeah because it was
based on the manga and that whatever
James Cameron farted out his ears Rob
Rob he can fart it out Pocahontas did
very walls and you know did me right in
college where those movies came out so
it's like of course it's me
when when the Marines in those giant
mechs were singing toxic long so guys
that's about it go check it out you want
a sequel I want to see it's worth it so
that's it later right
you